MARC LESSER: Hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Hello.
Why don't we start with
two minutes of sitting, OK?
If you're eating,
don't worry about it.
You can mindfully eat.
So I want to suggest putting
things away and finding a way
to sit where you can
be alert and relaxed.
Literally we're going to
do this for two minutes.
I'm going to time it.
Simply noticing what it's like
sitting here in this chair,
noticing the transition
from whatever activity
you were doing to stopping,
to arriving, to being here.
Again, simply
noticing sensations
of butt on chair, feet on
floor, noticing your shoulders,
noticing that you are
breathing, holding up your chin,
maybe relaxing, relaxing
the muscles in your face,
relaxing the jaw,
just seeing what's
possible to just
fully arrive here now.
Checking in with your body,
checking in with your breath,
noticing your thoughts, whether
your thoughts are coming
quickly or your mind is calm,
just noticing and seeing
if you can come back to
the breath, the body,
perhaps even checking
in with your own heart,
what is your deepest
feelings, mood, aspiration,
however you define heart.
Great, and let's gently
bring our attention
being back here with
each other in the room.
Well, I want to
start with a poem.
"When your eyes are tired,
the world is tired also.
When your vision has gone, no
part of the world can find you.
When your vision is gone, no
Time to go into
the darkness where
the night has eyes
to recognize its own.
There, you can be sure
you are not beyond love.
There in the night,
in the darkness,
you can be sure you
are not beyond love.
The dark will be
your womb tonight.
The night will
give you a horizon
further than you can see.
You must learn one thing-- the
world was made to be free in.
world was made to be free in."
This is part of a
poem by David Whyte.
And I particularly
love this line.
And his description of when
he was writing this poem
was that he was by himself in
a cabin, dark, rainy night,
and he wrote the line "You
must learn one thing,"
and didn't know what was
going to happen next.
And he could feel the hairs
on the back of his neck,
and what appeared
were the words,
"the world was made
to be free in."
And I realize part of why I
love this poem and this line
so much is that I think
feel like this has really
been the burning question
for much of my life,
is what does it mean to be free?
What does it really
mean to be free?
What stops us from being free?
And the subject here is
poetry and pragmatism as a way
into understanding and
practicing mindfulness.
And in a way to me,
this word "mindfulness"
really means the
practice of freedom.
It's the practice of
how we can be free.
And there's so many very
practical day-to-day ways
in which we're not free.
Several years ago I was
driving down to Google
to teach a Search
Inside Yourself Class.
Actually, this was one I
was co-teaching with Meng.
And as I was driving down
from my home in the North Bay
down to Mountain
View, I could feel
myself getting more
and more anxious.
And I started
remembering that I was
going to be rated by every
person in the classroom, one
to five, on how
well I interacted,
how knowledgeable I was.
And the more I thought
about that, the more anxious
I was getting.
And while I was driving
down, I slipped in a lecture
by David Whyte.
And I was listening lecture.
I felt myself becoming
freer and freer.
And I thought, screw
those Google people.
I don't care.
I don't care how they rate me.
I'm just going to completely
show up and be there as fully
and with as much love and
freedom as I possibly can.
And I got out of my
car, and Meng and I
started teaching this class.
And during the break an hour
into it, Meng turned to me
and said, what happened to you?
He said, you're
usually pretty good,
but you were really good today.
And I told him that story.
And I felt like I was able
to, in that moment, just
show up and be free.
So there's something very
freeing about poetry.
And to me, although I'm
reading some poetry,
there's also something very
inspirational, aspirational
about poetry.
And in a way, our lives are all
inspirational, aspirational,
mysterious.
We don't really know what it
means to be a human being.
We don't really know
what consciousness is.
And in terms of leadership,
I think of a wonderful quote
by the author of "The Little
Prince" in which he says,
if you want to build a
ship, don't teach people
to gather wood and to use
tools and order them about.
Instead, teach them to yearn
for the vastness of the sea.
Teach people to yearn for
the vastness of the sea.
And to me, this is
how I would describe
a core part of leadership
and using poetry and using
mindfulness.
So mindfulness is this wide,
wide, poetic, beautiful sense
of how we can live in the world.
But at the same time,
what about the pragmatic?
What about the world of
stuff, the world of buildings,
the world of data and research,
the world of org charts?
And I would say that this,
too, is mindfulness practice
and that it's also a
path toward freedom
and that we don't need to
choose between the poetic
and the pragmatic.
And it's not that we want
to find some middle ground.
In fact, I think part of what
we want to do, I believe,
as mindfulness practitioners,
is to really embrace the poetry,
to embrace the mystery, the
inspirational, the feelings.
What is it that brings us alive?
What is it that most
brings you alive?
In fact, in that poem that I
read, the very last lines are,
"anything that does
not bring you alive
is too small for you."
Anything that does not bring
you alive is too small for you.
So I think this is a huge part
of stepping into mindfulness
practice is noticing, paying
attention to feelings,
paying attention to
what brings you alive.
And at the same time, we have to
take care of our communication,
being pragmatically clear.
We have to take care of things
like money, like making sure
that we understand the practical
parts of being a human being.
And I want to mention, want
to bring in the organization
that I'm now the CEO
of, which is silly.
It's a silly organization.
And its SIYLI, Search Inside
Yourself Leadership Institute.
And the mission
and vision of SIYLI
is that all leaders in the world
are wise and compassionate.
You just got it.
[LAUGHS_]
All leaders in the world
are wise and compassionate,
thus creating the
conditions for world peace.
Very poetic, right?
All leaders in the world
are wise and compassionate,
thus creating the
conditions for world peace--
so poetic, aspirational,
kind of impossible,
sounds like, how could this be?
But there's a pragmatic
element to it.
We're really looking
at, what does
it mean to train wise and
compassionate leaders?
How will we know
if we succeeded?
What does it mean to help create
the conditions for world peace?
How can we actually
make a difference
in things like violence
and bias and inequality?
Can we actually be part
of measuring and helping
to make a difference
in solving some
of these large, large issues?
But also, I think
the starting point
is, how can we make
ourselves more peaceful?
How can we become more peaceful?
How can we bring peace
to our daily lives,
whether it's at Google
or the people we interact
with in the grocery
store or outside?
In all our
relationships, how can we
make ourselves more peaceful?
And again, there's
very much a poetic part
of that as well as
a practical part.
The poetic part is the
aspiration, the aspiration
to be more aware, to
see our blind spots,
to bring more compassion into
the world, to help others.
Again, to me in a
way these are where
the poetic and the practical
seem to come together.
And again, this is the sense
of mindfulness practice.
In a way there's a
balance piece to it,
but there's also a way in which
to be fully inspirational,
mysterious, poetic.
So I want to encourage
everyone to bring more poetry
into your life, even if it's
just listening to poetry,
but looking at what is
it that brings you alive.
What is it that fully
brings you alive?
I had a teacher of mine
when I was a young Zen
student living at
Green Gulch Farm.
A teacher named
Harry Roberts used
to say that being a human
being is very simple.
We just need to ask and
answer three questions.
Very simple being a human
being-- three questions we just
need to ask and answer.
What do you want?
What you have to do to get it?
And can you pay the price?
And Harry would then,
after saying this,
let out this huge
belly laugh, saying,
real simple, very few people
ask the first question,
what do you want?
What do you want?
And there's something
both extremely poetic,
inspirational, mysterious about
just asking that question,
like how do you
know what you want?
It's a dangerous question.
What if you really
each day ask yourself,
what's really important to me?
What's really in my heart?
And then the "What you
have to do to get it?"
is kind of practical.
Then it's like,
OK, what do you do?
What do I actually do?
Like maybe I have
to go to law school.
Maybe I have to learn a
different kind of mathematics
or coding or something
in order to be
able to fulfill whatever
that question is.
Maybe I need to learn to
dance or learn a language.
Maybe I need to take a risk.
And then also the third
part, can I pay the price,
is also very, very practical.
So to me, this image is
this, what do you want?--
the balance of being both
very poetic and very practical
at the same time.
So there's something
really powerfully
difficult and challenging
about being in this human form.
One of the things that
I'm fond of saying
is that being a human
being is a tough gig.
Being a human being
is a tough gig.
And here we are,
we're born, there's
all kinds of difficulties that
most of us have in growing up.
I think part of what
brought me to this question
about what does
it mean to be free
was for me growing up with
a manic depressive father
and in a family where things
like feelings and difficulties
and even mental illness were
all swept under the rug,
that it wasn't something that
anyone ever talked about.
Yet I could feel it.
I could feel the trauma of that.
I could feel in my body the
lack of freedom of that.
And I notice these
days when I walk
into a room, which, it's
very often these days I walk
into room of very
successful business people
who on the surface I
really have it together.
I did a workshop not too
long ago with 150 salespeople
from a large tech
company who flew
in from all around the
world for a Search Inside
Yourself workshop.
And this was a
jacket-and-tie culture.
And I noticed little
by little by little
as we were having
conversations--
they were talking
with each other,
we were practicing mindfulness,
practicing meditation--
they started to all kind
of follow apart a bit.
And you kind of
see that there was
this humanness underneath the
gloss of having it together.
And one of the
assumptions that I make
and one of the
assumptions that I think
is a really important
assumption in mindfulness
and in Search Inside Yourself,
is that the more we can bring
in this humanness,
the more we can bring
in the poetry combined
with the pragmatic,
the more we'll actually
be able to get done,
as leaders and as people
and organizations.
For many, many
years, I think it was
thought that we needed
to take the humanness out
of organizations.
There was an expression
about leaving your soul
in the parking lot.
And these days, I think part of
why organizations like Google
and many others all
around the world
are embracing
mindfulness practice
is because there's now more
agreement and this big aha,
that actually we're no longer
working on assembly lines.
We're now working
in places where
people need to communicate with
each other, where everything
is done in teams.
So I want to bring in the how.
So I feel like I'm raising
a variety of questions
around the importance of
poetry, the importance of asking
yourself the question, what
does it mean to be free?
What is freedom?
And what's the relationship
between mindfulness practice
and freedom?
Well, in one way,
mindfulness practice
is the practice of freedom.
It's the practice
of being completely
present for whatever is.
So like my story of
driving down to Google,
I wasn't pushing
aside my anxiety.
I could really feel my anxiety,
but I could see that, in a way,
those feelings were getting
in the way of me just
being present, of
just showing up.
So how can we just show up?
How can we just be
with difficult feelings
and joyful feelings?
How can we totally
embrace and be
free in our own bodies and our
own skin with our own feelings?
And these seven principles,
some people in this room
it's going to be familiar to.
One of the programs that
we have here at Google
is called the Train
the Trainer program,
in which we're working
with small groups of people
who are training to teach the
Search Inside Yourself program.
And at one of those
early sessions,
we had a full day with these
Train the Trainer Google
employees to teach them
how to teach meditation,
how to become a
mindfulness teacher,
how to be a meditation teacher.
And we brought in a man
named Norman Fisher, who
is a leading Zen teacher
and who was at this meeting.
And he was asked to speak
about how people could learn
to become mindfulness
and meditation teachers.
Actually, I still remember
it was a very funny scene.
We were sitting at a table,
and on one side of me was Meng,
and then the other
side of me was Norman.
And I had the agenda
in front of me.
And I pushed it
over to Norman, who
I think didn't
realize he was going
to be asked to give a talk.
And I kind of sort
of nudged Norman
and showed him that
his talk was coming up.
And he got out a
napkin an a pen and he
started making some notes.
And I was kind of
watching this happen.
And Norman's little
scribble actually
turned into what I'm calling
the seven principles.
And so these were initially
the seven principles
for how to become a
meditation teacher.
But as Norman was
describing these
and afterwards, I
thought, actually, this
is how I want to live my life.
And this is how I want us all
in the Search Inside Yourself
Leadership Institute
to work together.
And we've kind of customized,
revised Norman's original seven
principles and turn them
into how to live your life.
So to me, these principles
are the how to transcend
and to totally, fully
embrace and integrate
the poetry and pragmatism
of everyday life, the poetry
and pragmatism of
being a human being.
And in a way, to get
a sense of the depth
and breadth of this
word "mindfulness."
I think when I see
mindfulness in the press
and when people talk
about it, in a way it's
becoming smaller and smaller.
And I want to open it up.
I want to present that
actually mindfulness
is a lifetime endless
practice filled
with poetry, and at
the same time also
a very pragmatic
practice, right?
Count your breath and let
yourself be expensive.
And in a way, when I think of
poetry and pragmatism, in a way
it's a methodology, a way, a
path of uncrusting your heart,
opening your heart,
opening your mind,
allowing yourself
to be fully alive.
So, seven principles-- The first
principle is love the work.
Love the work.
So what is the work?
The work is the work
of being present,
the work of opening
your own awareness
and helping other people.
Maybe in a way it's that simple.
In some way, what if our main
focus, our main intention
in our daily life here at
work or wherever we are,
is becoming more aware, opening
up to seeing our blind spots,
seeing what stops
us from being free,
trying to become more present,
more feeling, bringing
our own awareness to
what we're feeling,
and looking for
opportunities to help others?
So in the context of becoming
a mindfulness and meditation
teacher, the work in a way is
to love meditation practice
and to love the work of bringing
the lessons from meditation
practice into one's daily life.
So this is the work, love the
work of being a human being.
Second is do the
work, to actually
have a sitting practice, have a
mindfulness practice, to spend
time becoming more aware
of your own feelings,
your own sensations,
tuning in to others.
This is a sense of what it
means to actually do the work.
The third principle of
these seven principles
is don't become an expert.
Now of course, we all
want to become experts.
And you can become an expert
in a particular field.
But when it comes to the
field of mindfulness,
when it comes to the field
of poetry and pragmatism,
the idea is to continually
uncrust our minds
and uncrust our hearts, to be
able to see that we're never
going to become
experts in mindfulness.
And in a way, one of
the beautiful things
about mindfulness,
in a way it's moving
from a sense of attainment
to non-attainment,
from a sense of grasping
to continually letting
go-- letting go.
There's an expression,
opening the hand of thought--
so in our minds we
want to become experts,
we want to know,
we want to succeed.
And those are all very
natural human desires.
But how can we let it go?
There's a saying that comes from
the Zen world-- in the expert's
mind, there are very
few possibilities.
In the beginner's
mind, there are many.
Beginner's mind-- many,
many possibilities.
In the expert's, there are few.
So again, just noticing,
noticing our own desire
to become an expert and looking
to see how we can let it go.
The fourth principle is
to let your own pain in,
to feel your own pain.
And I would add to that
to feel your own joy,
to feel your feelings, to
feel your feelings completely.
There's tremendous wisdom
in our emotional life.
There's a beautiful
little video that we
show during the
Search Inside Yourself
program of Daniel Goleman
looking at the brain
science of our emotional
life, and in which
he uses the words "the
wisdom of the emotions
is not just a pretty
phrase," that there's
some real, wonderful,
amazing wisdom
in our own emotional lives.
And the fifth of
these seven principles
is to feel the pain
of others, right?
So if you want-- whether it's
becoming a meditation teacher
or becoming a leader or someone
who's working effectively
on a team, it's tuning
into the feelings of others
and noticing that
everyone brings
a certain pain, a certain
difficulty, a certain anxiety.
It's part of being a human being
and just being able to tune
into that.
The sixth principle is to depend
on others-- depend on others.
Everything we do in our
lives, we don't even see it,
because it's so-- a
little bit like fish
not seeing the water
that they're swimming in.
To me, depending on others
is like that, that whether it
comes to this room
or the wonderful food
that we just ate over in the
cafe, even the clean air,
to be able to have
clean air, requires
that others help to
keep the air clean.
I'm going to tell little story
about depending on others,
which was when I once co-taught
a one-day workshop, a Search
Inside Yourself workshop
here at Google in which I was
co-teaching with a
Google employee, who
was teaching for the first time.
And we were about to walk
out onto the stage like this,
and there were maybe 50 or
60 executives in the room.
And as we were about to walk
out, she turns to me and says,
I think I'm going to
either vomit or faint.
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know what I'm
doing up here teaching
mindfulness and
emotional intelligence.
I feel like a fraud.
I'm really, really
frightened, and I
don't think I can go out there.
And I said, well,
I get nervous, too.
And I'm nervous about
going out there.
But let's depend on
each other out there.
I said, what if my job
when we go out there
is to make you look
good, and your job
is to make me look good?
And I said, and you
have a much tougher job.
[LAUGHTER]
But if you forget what
you're going to say,
if you get nervous, if you
drop it, I'll be right there.
I'll be right there.
And she gulped.
And we went out, and she
went out, started talking,
and I could see she was
just completely relaxed.
And we gave each
other a little hidden
thumbs up as we
made eye contact.
And to me, it was
just a beautiful way
that-- it actually
calmed me down,
her being so transparent
and willing to share
her nervousness.
And it was a way to really
to make it explicit,
the way that we were
depending on others.
And I think, again,
I would encourage
you to allow yourself to see
how you depend on others.
I recently not too long ago
had hip replacement surgery.
I had one of my hips replaced.
And one of the amazing things
about it was for a week or so,
not being able to get dressed by
myself or get in and out of bed
and feeling the
vulnerability and beauty
of just depending
on someone else.
And I'm not sure exactly
why-- I think it was partly
because of that and partly
because of the surgery,
but I found myself
falling apart quite a bit.
I would hear a song
and just start to cry.
Or I'd hear a line from a movie,
and I would just be weeping.
And it just felt
actually so wonderful.
In fact, I find myself
a little grasping,
because I want to be
like that all the time.
And there's something very, very
enlivening about falling apart,
depending on others
to pick you up.
People will pick-- it's amazing.
So often we don't
want to fall apart.
We don't want to
depend on others.
A lot of us don't even
like to ask for anything
or make a request.
So there's something
very beautiful,
something very powerful
about depending on others.
And the last practice
is keep making
it simpler-- really hard
one, a really hard one.
Keep making it simpler.
Things seem to get so
complicated, very, very,
very easily without
us even being
aware of how
complicated it can be.
But what about the practice?
And this is what I love
about mindfulness practice,
mindfulness meditation
practice, is
what could be
simpler than bringing
your attention to your breath,
noticing that you're breathing?
So when things get
very complicated,
even during a very
busy, complex day,
you can always
actually just stop
and pause and bring your
attention to your breath,
to your body.
Ask yourself, what am I feeling?
And it actually could take about
5 or 10 seconds to do that.
And it can actually
be a big time saver.
It doesn't take any extra time.
That time is going to happen.
You could be anxious and frantic
and not do that, and then it
often-- the things that
take the most time, I find,
in the world of work are
unraveling the stupid things
that I've said or that
somebody else has said.
And so to keep it
simple, this is
the tool of our business life.
Stephen Covey used to
talk about sharpening
the saw, this image of the
carpenter that doesn't have
time to stop and sharpen their
saw because they're too busy.
And then they're
sawing and sawing
and sawing with this dull blade
and not getting anything done,
but they still can't
stop-- too busy.
So in this case, what
I love about that image
is that we are the saw.
And to me, mindfulness practice
and mindfulness meditation
practice is stopping to sharpen
the saw so that whatever
we do actually has more
impact, more possibility, more
effectiveness.
And in a way, a core practice
has to do with the question,
are we building walls, or
are we building bridges?
In each moment of your life, to
notice are you building walls,
or are you building bridges?
And bridges with yourself--
are you being true to yourself?
Are you being true
to your own feelings?
Are you deeply asking that
question, what do you want?
Do you pay attention?
Do you allow your own
feelings, intuition, to arise?
So there's that bridge
to your own feelings,
and then are you
actually noticing
that the world isn't
all you, that there
are a lot of people out
there who depend on you
and who you depend on?
So are you building walls?
Are you crusting your heart?
Is your heart
getting more crusted?
Is your own thinking
getting more concretized?
Or are you developing
more flexibility?
And I want to
encourage you-- again,
the seven principles are
actually things you can do.
And poetry and
pragmatism are kind
of the container for holding
these seven practices.
And I want to end by
reading a short poem.
And this is a poem by Rilke,
the German poet Rilke.
I live my life in
growing orbits,
which move out over the
things of the world.
I live my life in
growing orbits,
which move out over the
things of the world.
Perhaps I can never
achieve the last.
But that will be my attempt.
Perhaps I can never
achieve the last,
perhaps I can never get
to the furthest orbit.
Perhaps I'll never
be able to be as wide
and perhaps I'll never
be able to achieve
as much as I want to achieve.
But that will be my attempt.
I'm circling.
I'm circling around God.
I'm circling around
an ancient tower.
And I've been circling
for 1,000 years.
I've been circling
And I still don't
know if I'm a falcon
or a storm or a great song.
And I still don't
know if I'm a falcon
or a storm or a great song.
So you can see, I've chosen
to be a falcon this morning,
circling around.
So to me, this is poetry, right?
I'm reading poetry, very poetic.
But there's something to me
very practical about when
we sit down, when we sit down
in a chair or on our cushion,
and we bring our attention
to our breath and our body,
or when we get up
from our cushion
and we go off into
the world, being
curious and present
and interested.
We don't know what will happen.
We don't even know,
really, who or what we are.
And it's a beautiful thing.
It's a beautiful thing to not
know whether you are a falcon
or maybe you are a storm, right?
Some days are stormy.
Or a great song-- not just
a song, but a great song.
So I want us to try something.
Actually, how about if everybody
stands up for a second?
And how about finding a partner?
Find someone in the room,
maybe that you don't know.
But find someone without
talking and have a seat.
Have a seat.
Each person is going to speak
for three whole minutes.
During your three
minutes, the other person
is not going to ask you
questions or interrupt.
This is called-- we're going
to do mindful listening here,
three minutes.
And then it will switch.
The other person will
have three minutes.
I'm fond of saying,
if you run out
of something to say
in your three minutes,
just sit there uncomfortably.
Don't just stop and have
the other person go.
It's OK.
Actually, is one of
the wonderful things
about meditation
and mindfulness.
You can always choose to
do nothing, and it's OK.
This is a place
where doing nothing
can be a comfortable place.
And if it's uncomfortable,
great-- great-- uncomfortable--
uncomfortable.
We're not trying to
avoid discomfort.
It's OK.
It's really OK.
That is so freeing.
It's so freaking
freeing if you can
let go of needing to be
comfortable all the time.
OK, so my suggested question,
suggested topic is just talk
for three minutes about how
might you describe the poetry
and pragmatism of your own life?
Three minutes, however
it comes up for you.
How might you-- just talk.
And I want to
suggest-- pretend you
know what you're doing here.
[LAUGHTER]
You might have no idea
what the assignment is
or what the hell is--?
But just pretend.
And speak with as much
conviction and clarity
as you can muster.
Here's how my life
is poetic, and here's
how my life is pragmatic.
One other topic
possibility is anything
you want to talk about.
[LAUGHTER]
You might actually--
I don't know
what's happening in
your life right now.
You might not, either.
But sometimes it can
just be a great gift
having someone listen to
you for three minutes.
So there might be something
that's up for you.
So feel free to talk
about whatever you want.
So let's just take a breath.
Let's all just breathe
together and relax.
Whatever you've prepared to
say already, forget about it.
Trust that you'll know when
it's your turn to speak.
So how about if the person
with the shortest hair
is going to be Person A.
Person with the shortest hair
is Person A. So Person A,
you have three minutes.
I'll ring a bell at three
minutes, and then we'll switch.
So go ahead.
[CHATTER]
[BELL RINGING]
OK, so the first
person should finish.
And then let's go right
to the second person.
You have three minutes to talk
about poetry and pragmatism,
OK?
[CHATTER]
[BELL RINGING]
OK, let's finish, and
thank your partners.
And then let's come on back.
We have a few minutes
for comments, questions
about how that-- I'm really
curious how that went,
but anything else anyone
wants to add, ask, comment on.
See, I'm not comfortable
with silence.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I think is very
interesting how one thing leads
to another one and
you start opening up.
I think at some
point-- I don't know
what happened to
other people, but you
need to close the
doors, because you
realize that you are getting
deeper and deeper into things
that you didn't think
about two minutes ago-- I
mean six minutes ago.
So I thought that was very
interesting, that part.
MARC LESSER: So the part about
just noticing the opening up.
AUDIENCE: Yes, and I think we
both were very open about what
we were talking-- I
don't think we really
knew what we were talking about.
[LAUGHTER]
But it was sincere.
You could feel it.
That's what I mean.
You could feel the sincerity.
AUDIENCE: From one
view, these two things
could be viewed as a
paradox and both seemingly
oppositional to each other yet
coexisting at the same time.
And I know you've written
a lot about paradox.
I'm wondering if you could
speak a little bit about how
the usefulness of paradox and
now it shows up in our lives.
MARC LESSER: Yeah, I
think I once-- there's
this wonderful quote that's
"if it's not paradoxical,
it's not true."
And I Googled to see who said
it, and it said Marc Lesser.
[LAUGHTER]
I know someone else
said it before me.
But in some way, being
a human being is just
incredibly
paradoxical, in that we
don't know-- how
did we get here?
How did we get here?
What are we doing here?
What is consciousness?
So there's that.
There's the big paradox.
But then in
everything we do, like
some of my favorite
paradoxes are
"be confident and
question everything."
Fight for change
and accept what is.
Like, of course-- of course
we have to fight for change.
If you're always finding,
though, it's not so good.
If you're always
accepting, not so good.
We have to do both.
So I think yes, there's
something very poetic
about the human condition--
so we should fully
go there-- and practical, right?
Like we have one minute left.
I was noticing my
shoes could be shinier.
Matt, you've got
the shiniest shoes.
You might have
holes in your socks,
but your shoes are really shiny.
[LAUGHTER]
To notice the paradoxes
and to embrace them
and in a way to see--
right, so I wrote a book
on this called "Know
Yourself, Forget Yourself."
That's what I think of as
also a very core practice.
Know yourself, right?
We want to know
ourselves, right?
It comes from--
there's a famous Zen
guy from the 13th
century named Dogen
who said, to study the
way-- and it's funny.
Even "the way"-- the
way means to study
what it means to
be a human being.
To study what it means
to be human being
is to study the self, right?
You study the self.
Then the next line of this piece
of writing, "to study the self
is to forget the self."
It's like, huh?
But it's so like,
yeah, because we
don't want to go around
being self-conscious.
It's not about being
self-conscious.
It's about being free, right?
But you have to-- you can't
just go right-- a lot of people
try to go right to
self-forgetting.
It doesn't work so well.
I sometimes see it
as a PES disease
is what they call it-- Premature
Enlightenment Syndrome.
[LAUGHTER]
This sense that, oh,
I don't have a self.
Well, that's not-- so we want
to have a really healthy self.
And we want to be able to
not be so self-conscious,
to find freedom there.
And then the other
line, to study the way
is to study the self.
To study the self is
to forget the self.
To forget the self is to
become intimately connected
to all people and all things.
It's to lose any
sense of separation.
So in a way, that's a
wonderful path of practice,
self-study, self-forgetting,
drop all disconnect.
See that there
is-- again, that's
in a way the real
freedom is to see
that our separateness
is an illusion.
It's a very compelling illusion.
But it's an illusion.
Our separateness is an illusion.
And maybe that's a really
good note to end on.
Thank you all very much.
[APPLAUSE]